what's up y'all my name is Ian and I'm
back with another episode of IBM Tech
now I'm going to dive into the latest
and greatest IBM news and announcements
including 25 years of Java on zos the
15th consecutive time that IBM was named
a leader in the Gartner magic quadrant
for primary storage and five IBM
products named to the truss radius best
software list
but first a bit of news from The Wider
Tech world
Swedish and danish researchers conducted
a successful experiment last week that
could make the internet faster and more
energy efficient using a laser-powered
Chip and A specialized light creating
device the Scandinavians transmitted
1.84 petabytes of data in a single
second setting a new world record
how much is 1.84 petabytes you ask well
it's roughly the equivalent of the
entire internet about two times over
moving that much data would typically
require over a thousand lasers but
according to the Washington Post the new
chip works by using a single laser to
create a rainbow of colors through a
device called a frequency column these
arrays of light carry data through fiber
optic cables in a faster less energy
consuming manner
bringing greater Energy Efficiency to
the web is a big deal because the
internet accounts for roughly 10 percent
of global electricity consumption the
researchers said the new chip is years
away from mainstream use but the
development is extremely exciting
nonetheless
and now let's dive into what's going on
at IBM
so today's news is brought to you by the
Numbers 25 15 and 5.
to start 25 years ago IBM released its
first SDK for Java on IBM Z systems
Hardware
and since then Java has been a key
component of delivering Innovation
performance and portability on IBM Z
systems
a quarter Century later Java remains one
of the top development languages for
modern Enterprise applications
and the design principles and resulting
benefits of an SDK for Java on Z systems
remain consistent
this versatile programming language has
helped many world-class customers build
highly robust scalable and reliable
modern Enterprise applications with us
for example a Truvia AG is using Java to
accelerate the creation of new Services
while extending the life and value of
its core applications alongside COBOL
within IMS on IBM Z systems
we're also excited about the future of
java development at IBM in 2021 We Begin
the next phase of our Java journey by
rebranding our IBM SDK to IBM submaru
runtime certified Edition for zos
to learn more about the 25 years of IBM
and Java check out the link I've got in
the description of this video
next up for the 15th consecutive time
IBM has achieved in industry-leading
position in the 2022 Gartner magic
quadrant for primary storage
the Gartner mq provides a graphical
competitive positioning of four types of
Technology providers and IBM was named
the leader the highest distinction based
upon ability to execute and completeness
of vision
IBM has an unparalleled Legacy in data
storage with inventions that include the
floppy disk the hard disk drive magnetic
stripe readers and more
We Believe being recognized as a leader
in the magic quadrant for primary
storage validates the ongoing
Innovations developed by our Global team
of Engineers product managers and
marketers
it also highlights the strength of the
IBM storage platform which incorporates
countless proprietary Technologies
developed by our scientists and
researchers
to learn more about IBM Storage
Solutions and the Gartner mq hit the
link below
to wrap things up today we're excited to
announce that five IBM offerings have
made the first ever trust radius best
software list to make the list products
must have over 40 reviews from the past
year and have maintained a TR score of
7.5 or higher
IBM's products went a bit above and
beyond by maintaining an overall average
rating of 9.0 demonstrating their
commitment to transparency Improvement
and user insights
the five products recognized by trust
radius are IBM Watson assistant IBM
process mining IBM power servers IBM
power virtual servers and IBM flash
system
a big congrats to the teams who worked
on these solutions for all they do to
keep our customers happy to learn more
about these products and the trust
radius best software list hit the link
below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now